welche krise fällt euch als erstes ein
wenn ihr an die linke denkt dass 4,9
prozent debakel bei der bundestagswahl
der ewige streit mit sarah wagenknecht
und oskar lafontaine aus dritte
rücktritte oder der jüngste sexismus
kann da die liste ist lang schlimmer
geht immer das gilt für die linke keine
andere partei hat so viel selbst
zerstörungspotenzial dabei ist dort
eigentlich allen klar um was es jetzt
geht es geht um viel es geht um nichts
weniger als um die existenz der partei
die linke wenn wir in diesen vier jahren
das nicht erfolgreich machen dann macht
diese fraktion das licht aus dass die
linke ein problem erkennt heißt
allerdings noch lange nicht dass sie es
löst begleiten wir also gerade eine
partei in den untergang und brauchen wir
die linke überhaupt nur
[Applaus]
mein name ist andrea maurer und ich bin
hier im zdf hauptstadtstudio unter
anderem zuständig für die linke also
eigentlich bin ich so was wie
parteipolitische dauerkrisen
berichterstatterin die ursprüngliche
spiegel enthüllung dass es bei der
hessischen linken über jahre zu
sexuellen übergriffen gekommen sein soll
die hatte aber selbst für diese krisen
partei noch einmal eine neue dimension
[Musik]
warum dass die parteien und einen
schritt weiter in den abgrund treibt
zwei gründe erstens und ganz
grundsätzlich mit der linken also einer
partei die für feminismus eintritt das
erschüttert das selbstverständnis und
das image dieser partei im kern unter
dem hashtag linke mito sammelt sich da
gerade auch ziemlich viel wut vor allem
im linken jugendverband wenn ich mit
mitgliedern des jugendverbandes spreche
dann klingt es so als sei sexismus in
der parteistruktur also alles andere als
ein einzelfall wo wir jetzt
jugendverband wissen gerade von
bundesweit über 60 betroffenen die
vorwürfe von sexueller gewalt von
parteimitgliedern der linken vor bringen
das sind funktionäre dabei das und
mandatsträger dabei
und gerade deshalb wird es ebenso oft
unter den tisch gekehrt das ist so ein
system des schweigens was so krage
langsam aufbricht oder hier die
landesvorsitzende der linken in
rheinland pfalz seit letztem jahr auch
mitglied des parteivorstandes hört mal
was die mir gesagt hat ich kann dann
natürlich auch aus teilen der vertrauens
gruppe des parteivorstandes nicht
wirklich ins detail gehen aber es gibt
und das schon seit jahren eigentlich
seit beginn der partei gibt es da
vorfälle ich glaube dass es für viele
einfach sehr schwer ist zu realisieren
dass wir eben auch nicht davor gefeit
sind und dass man dann gerne
anstatt es aufzuarbeiten sagt wir
versuchen das jetzt klein zu halten und
dass das 60 grad schon in der woche nach
der enthüllung jedenfalls hat sich
abgezeichnet dass hessen möglicherweise
nur die spitze des eisbergs ist dass
sexismus wohl auch andere landesverbände
betrifft die partei und auch die
fraktion und in der tat jetzt lesen wir
von übergriffen und strukturellem
sexismus vorwürfen in der
linken-bundestagsfraktion von einem
grund klima das auch über griffiges
verhalten beflügelt ist da die rede oder
auch von einzelnen fällen die sich
mutmaßlich im bereich des strafbaren
bewegen die vorwürfe rollen also gerade
nur so über partei und fraktion hinweg
und sie haben das potenzial köpfe zum
rollen zu bringen die wucht der
anschuldigung hat als erstes
parteichefin janine wissler erreicht es
geht nämlich bei den vorwürfen von
hessen nicht nur um sexismus im
hessischen landesverband also dort wo
sie selbst über zehn jahre
fraktionschefin war sondern es geht auch
um den ehemaligen lebensgefährten von
janine wissler selbst ein mitarbeiter
der fraktion wissler sagt sie habe nur
gewusst dass sie ihr langjähriger freund
betrübt weil ihr die frau die war damals
18 im mai 2018 screenshots von
nachrichten zugeschickt hat sie hat sich
daraufhin von dem mann getrennt sie sei
aber von dieser frau die jetzt behauptet
von dem mann sexuell genötigt worden zu
sein nie um hilfe gebeten worden und
habe auch von missbrauch nichts gewusst
hier ist ihr dementi meine damen und
herren ich weise die unterstellung ich
hätte bereits vor ende 20 21 kenntnis
über vorwürfe von sexueller belästigung
landesverband hessen gehabt entschieden
zurück ich verweise auf meine
schriftliche erklärung dort habe ich
alle daten aufgeführt und ich bin sofort
tätig geworden als ich von diesen
vorwürfen erfahren habe im umfeld von
janine wissler sind alle entsetzt über
die berichterstattung eine vertraute von
wisla twittert der artikel im spiegel
ist auch ein sexistisches lehrstück die
einzige die mit klarnamen öffentlich
durch den dreck gezogen wird ist eine
betrogene frau das ist die deutung mit
der wissler unter anderem erklären will
warum sie nicht zurücktritt als
betrogene frau ist sie sozusagen selbst
opfer opfer auch einer sexistischen
berichterstattung die politische
tragweite die sieht sie offenbar nicht
denn ihr nicht rücktritt der bedeutet
dass sie vorsitzende einer partei bleibt
die aufklären muss auch das nicht wissen
oder wissen von ihr selbst dass einige
betroffene einer solchen aufklärung
nicht trauen das liegt natürlich auf der
hand janine wissler ist nun also
angeschlagene vorsitzende einer
angeschlagenen partei die ums überleben
kämpft und das ist auch die politische
dimension dieses skandals die vor allem
noch durch 1 massiv verstärkt wird durch
das rücktritts drama das sich kurz nach
den enthüllungen von hessen in der
linken abgespielt hat
[Musik]
vier tage nach der veröffentlichung
tritt die parteichefin zurück aber nein
eben nicht janine wissler sondern sie
hier susanne hennig welt so die andere
vorsitzende in der doppelspitze er warum
die denn jetzt das war auch meine erste
reaktion in ihrem statement nennt hennig
welt so drei gründe erstens ihr
privatleben und ihren achtjährigen sohn
2 die gescheiterte erneuerung der partei
und drittens die jüngsten sexismus
vorwürfe ihre co-chefin janine wissler
erwähnt sie übrigens mit keinem wort
schreibt aber erneuerung braucht neue
gesichter also gesichter im plural
wissler war also durchaus mitgemeint
janine wissler aber wir bleiben
zumindest bis zu den beschlossenen
neuwahlen im juni wie susanne hennig
werde so das findet das lässt sich
erahnen wenn man mit ihrer engen
vertrauten spricht katja maurer der
stellvertretenden fraktionsvorsitzenden
in thüringen die fordert nun öffentlich
den rücktritt von whistler und da hat
sie sicherlich rücksprache gehalten ich
glaube dass man es forschern natürlich
sehr viel verantwortung trägt die sind
ja auch sehr offensiv nach vorne
gegangen und haben beide gesagt dass er
die partei verändern wollen und dieses
projekt ist derzeit einfach gescheitert
und deswegen denke ich natürlich dass
beide personen auch die verantwortung
dafür tragen müssen ganz schön krass
oder völlige zerrüttung beim frauenduo
der linken die sich in zukunft nun
weiter als fraktionskollegin begegnen
werden wie konnte es eigentlich so weit
kommen
[Musik]
dass susanne hennig welt so die schnauze
voll haben könnte das hat sich schon
nach der desaströsen saarland fall
angedeutet dass war die wahl ihr
erinnert euch vielleicht wo kurz zuvor
linken ikone oskar lafontaine aus der
partei ausgetreten ist und seiner partei
damit den todesstoß versetzt hat 2,6
prozentpunkte ein absturz um zehn
prozentpunkte im vergleich zur letzten
wahl und um fast 20 prozentpunkte im
vergleich zu 2009 als lafontaine selbst
spitzenkandidat an er habe am tag nach
der wahl sagt susanne hennig welt so in
der bundespressekonferenz diesen
denkwürdigen satz ich würde
es bringen 50 zu fühlen uns relativ hoch
dazu müsst ihr auch wissen hennig welt
so das war die die versöhnung mit oskar
und sarah versucht hat sie war im
saarland sie ist mit beiden im
bundestagswahlkampf aufgetreten dass
lafontaine am ende seine partei noch mal
derart ins verderben stürzt das ist auch
ein tiefschlag für hennig welt so einer
von ziemlich vielen tiefschlägen noch im
januar hat susanne hennig welt so die
die partei verjüngen erneuern
regierungsfähig machen wollte in einem
interview von der entfremdung zwischen
fraktion und partei gesprochen gemeint
hat sie damals auch das die fraktionen
den einzigen ausschussvorsitz für die
linke im bundestag nämlich den für klima
und energie
ausgerechnet dem mann gibt der von klima
aktivismus so gar nichts hält klaus
ernst ehemalige parteichef nord stream
zwei befürworter
auch porsche klaus genannt ihr könnt
euch denken wie sauer klaus ernst damals
war das handy quält sich so deutlich
gegen in positioniert und ihr könnt euch
sicher denken wie klaus ernst nun nach
dem rücktritt von susanne hennig welt so
klingt genau ziemlich erfreut weil damit
natürlich auch die neuwahlen eingeleitet
werden die ich eigentlich auch immer
wollte und insofern ist der rücktritt
von honeywell so ist wirklich eine
chance für die partei diesen und viele
andere machtkämpfe um die
programmatische erneuerung der partei
hat susanne hennig welt so verloren in
einem zeitungsinterview sagt ihr
politischer mentor bodo ramelow dazu
diese sehr traurigen und waren sätze
über seine partei und das politische
berlin ich habe hennig welt so damals
abgeraten nach berlin zu gehen ich habe
ihr gesagt du täuscht sich dieses immer
wieder gemeinsame reden dass wir in
thüringen praktizieren ist nicht die
normalität in der partei sie hat gesagt
sie schafft es am ende hat sie es nicht
geschafft
und was heißt das jetzt für die linke
[Musik]
es eigentlich klar wofür die linke steht
und wer für die linke steht fragt ihr
euch auch oft wie eigentlich in der
linken zusammen passt was per parteibuch
zusammengehört werden etwa klaus ernst
ein interview mit lafontaine verlinkt in
dem der beklagt dass sich die linke zu
sehr auf sendern konzentriert statt auf
die soziale frage und dann schreibt wenn
wir uns nicht wieder auf unseren
gründungs konsens konzentrieren
verlieren wir nicht nur oscar daraufhin
antwortet ihm caren lay abgeordnete der
fraktion auch auf twitter dafür ist der
gründungs konsens der linken wir sind
eine sozialistisch feministische partei
und sendet ihm ein herzchen so geht das
eigentlich die ganze zeit die partei ist
im totalen richtungskampf dauernd und
die grundsatz konflikte die werden
einfach nicht gelöst wie haltet ihr es
mit der nato wie haltet ihr es mit
russland für wen wollt ihr eigentlich
politik machen wenn etwa sahra
wagenknecht fordert dass zuwanderung
begrenzt werden muss ihre partei aber
bleiberecht für alle fordert oder sich
wahrlich nicht prominent an die seite
der skeptiker stellt obwohl sich ihre
partei für impfungen aus spricht da weiß
keiner mehr was bei der linken
eigentlich sache ist dass fraktionschef
hauk mit dem wagenknecht lager ein
zweckbündnis geformt hat um
machttaktisch mehrheiten in der fraktion
zu sichern das nehmen ihm viele übel vor
allem im parteivorstand das bad nach dem
wahldesaster der bundestagswahl bei der
er ja auch spitzenkandidat war meinte im
amt bleiben zu können als sei nichts
gewesen das nehmen ihm auch ziemlich
viel über die lage jetzt nutzen manche
um eine neuwahl auch der fraktionsspitze
zu fordern also eigentlich den rücktritt
von bartsch neue legitimation heißt das
dann übersetzt wir brauchen auf einen
ebenen das hinterfragen von personal und
von inhalten und struktur und das
bedeutet selbstverständlich auch dass
die fraktionsführung eine neue
legitimation braucht so und jetzt ratet
mal was bat dazu sagt genau auf keinen
fall diese vereinzelte stimmen die sie
genannt haben kenne ich ja alle
persönlich und in jedem fall kann ich
den grund dafür erkennen aber gehen sie
davon aus dass das nicht passieren wird
also ihr seht das problem in dieser
partei sind und haben immer die anderen
und die linke wird in den nächsten
wochen wohl auch wenig zeit haben für
aufklärung des sexismus vorwürfen oder
programmatische erneuerung weil sie
einfach schon wieder mitten drin hängt
im machtkampf und der frage wer
eigentlich bleiben kann und wer
eigentlich gehen muss
[Musik]
ende juni ist der wahl und
programmparteitag in erfurt die wochen
bis dahin die könnten noch mal richtig
hässlich werden für die partei es stehen
zwei landtagswahlen in
schleswig-holstein und in nordrhein
westfalen und in beiden bundesländern
sind die umfragewerte schlecht laut
neuesten zdf politbarometer in
schleswig-holstein linke 3 prozent der
vielleicht letzte erfolgreiche linke
bodo ramelow der hat seine partei jetzt
vor dem untergang gewarnt es geht also
wirklich um alles und alles ist möglich
auch dass sich die fraktion auf spalte
zum beispiel es reichen ja drei
abgeordnete die aus der fraktion
austreten damit die ihren
fraktionsstatus im bundestag verliert
und damit zur frage aller fragen wer
oder was könnte diese partei überhaupt
noch retten was das kann ich euch ganz
klar sagen denn eigentlich sagen dass
fast alle in der partei
sie kriegen zeit nur nicht hin die
fraktion und die partei müssen endlich
an einem strang ziehen die frage wer die
linke eigentlich sein will die muss
beantwortet werden die partei muss
aufhören sich mit sich selbst zu
beschäftigen und sich auf ihre rolle in
der opposition konzentrieren denn wir
brauchen doch eine oppositionspartei
links der spd wenn die spd in der
regierung ist oder was meint ihr wer die
partei retten kann da ist die klare
antwort schon viel schwieriger denn die
dynamik der personaldebatte die hat ja
gerade erst begonnen ein paar namen die
in dieser debatte relevant werden
könnten kann ich euch aber schon mal
sagen janine wissler durchaus möglich
dass sie noch mal antritt sie selbst
hält es offen die nächsten wochen sind
da entscheidend wie sehr wird der
vorwurf der vertuschung an ihr kleben
bleiben wie sehr werden die möglichen
verluste bei den landtagswahlen ihr
zugerechneten trainern der
direktkandidat aus leipzig und damit
eine der drei lebensretter der partei
durch die sie ihren fraktionsstatus
sichern konnten jan korte
parlamentarischer geschäftsführer einer
der wenigen auf den sich viele partei
und fraktion einigen können aber korte
will nicht zumindest bislang er wollte
schon beim letzten mal nicht als es um
den parteivorsitz ging und er wollte
seinen hut nicht in den ring werfen nach
der bundestagswahl für eine
neuaufstellung an der fraktionsspitze
wenn es jetzt um alles geht könnte er
natürlich noch mal deutlicher gedrängt
werden und keine armin hofft merkt euch
diesen namen hoff ist staatskanzleichef
von bodo ramelow in erfurt
er ist eine art vordenker für die linke
und hat kürzlich seine ideen von einer
modernen sozialistischen
gerechtigkeitspartei formuliert so und
was meint ihr wer soll die partei
übernehmen wer soll sich zur wahl
stellen wie kann die linke gerettet
werden sollen sie überhaupt noch
gerettet werden schreibt gerne unten in
die kommentare und wie immer gilt
abonniert den kanal und schaut die
videos meiner kolleginnen und kollegen